so
that's an interesting distinction to
draw so if you look at the way tesla's
approaching the problem
and the way you're approaching the
problem which is very different than the
rest of the
self-driving car world so let's put them
aside
is you're treating most the driving task
is a machine learning problem
and the way tesla is approaching it is
with the multi-task learning
we break the task of driving into
hundreds of different desks
and you have this multi-headed neural
network that's very good at
performing each task and there there's
presumably something on top that's
stitching stuff together in order to uh
make control decisions policy decisions
about how you move the car
but what that allows you there's a
brilliance to this because it allows you
to um
master each task like lane detection
uh stop sign detection traffic light
detection uh drivable area segmentation
uh you know vehicle bicycle pedestrian
detection
uh there's some localization tasks in
there
also predicting uh
like yeah predicting how the the
entities in the scene are going to move
like everything is basically a machine
learning task well there's a
classification
segmentation prediction and
it's nice because you can have this
entire engine data engine that's mining
for edge cases
for each one of these tasks and you can
have people like engineers that are
basically masters of that task
like become the best person in the world
that uh as you talk about the cone guy
for uh for for waymo the good old phone
guy
the the becoming the best person in the
world at uh at uh
at cone detection i i so there's that's
a compelling notion from a supervised
learning perspective
automating much of the process of
educates discovery and retraining neural
network for each of the individual
perception tasks and then you're looking
at the machine learning in a more
holistic way
basically doing end-to-end learning on
the driving tasks
supervised trained on the data of the
actual
driving of people they used comma ai
like actual human drivers do manual
control plus the
moments of disengagement that uh
maybe with some labeling could indicate
the failure of the system
so you have the you have a huge amount
of data for
positive control of the vehicle like
successful control the vehicle
both maintaining the lane as as i think
you're also working on
longitudinal control of the vehicle and
then failure cases where the vehicle
does something wrong that
needs disengagement so like what
why do you think you're right and tesla
is wrong
on this and then do you think do you
think you'll come around the tesla way
do you think tesla will come around
to your way if you were to start a chess
engine company
would you hire a bishop guy see we have
uh this is monday
morning quarterbacking as uh
yes probably
so oh oh our rook guy oh we stole the
rook guy from that company oh we're
gonna have real good rooks
well there's not many pieces right
you can uh yeah there's not many
guys and gals to hire you just have a
few that work on the bishop
a few that work in the rook but is that
not ludicrous today to think about in
in the world of alpha zero but alpha
zero is the chest can so
the the fundamental question is how hard
is driving compared to chess
because so long term end to end
will be the right solution the question
is how many years away is that
end to end's gonna be the only solution
for level five for the only way
of course and of course tesla's gonna
come around to my way and if you're a
rook guy out there i'm sorry
the cone guy i don't know we're gonna
specialize each task we're gonna really
understand
rook placement yeah i understand the
intuition you have i mean that
that is very compelling notion that we
can learn the task
and to end like the same compelling
notion you might have for natural
language conversation
i'm not sure
because one thing you sneaked in there
is the assertion that
it's impossible to get to level five
without this kind of approach
i don't know if that's obvious i don't
know if that's obvious either i don't
actually uh mean that i think that it is
much easier
to get to level five with an end-to-end
approach i think that the other approach
is
doable but the magnitude of the
engineering challenge may exceed what
humanity is capable of
so but what do you think of the tesla
data engine approach which to me is an
active learning task is kind of
fascinating is
breaking it down into these multiple
tasks and mining their data
constantly for like edge cases for these
different tasks yeah but the tasks
themselves are not being learned this is
feature engineering
yeah i mean it's it's a it's a higher
abstraction level of feature engineering
for the different tasks
it's task engineering in a sense it's
slightly better feature engineering but
it still fundamentally is feature
engineering
and if anything about the history of ai
has taught us anything
it's that feature engineering approaches
will always be replaced and lose
to end to end now to be fair i cannot
really make
promises on timelines but i can say
that when you look at the code for
stockfish and the code for alpha zero
one is a lot shorter than the other a
lot more elegant required a lot less
programmer hours to write
yeah but there's a lot more murder
of bad
agents on the uh alpha zero
side by murder i mean uh
agents that played a game and failed
miserably yeah
oh oh in simulation that failure is less
costly
in in real world it's crazy do you mean
in practice like alpha zero has lost
games miserably
no well i haven't seen that no but i
know but
the the the the requirement for alpha
zero is a simulator
to be able to like evolution human
evolution
not human evolution biological evolution
of life on earth from the origin of life
has murdered trillions upon trillions of
organisms
on the path to us humans yeah so the
question is can
can we uh stitch together a human-like
object without having to go through the
entirety process of evolution
well no but do the evolution in
simulation yeah that's the question can
we simulate so do you have a sense
that's possible to simulate some
mu zero is exactly this mu zero is
is the solution to this mu zero i think
is going to look be looked back
as the canonical paper and i don't think
deep learning is everything i think that
there's still a bunch of things missing
to get there
but mu0 i think is going to be looked
back as the kind of cornerstone paper
um of this whole deep learning era
and mu0 is the solution to self-driving
cars you have to make a few tweaks to it
but mu0 does effectively that it does
those roll outs
and those murdering in in learned
simulator in a learned dynamics model
that's interesting it doesn't get enough
love i was blown away when i i was blown
away when i read that paper i'm like
you know okay i've always had a comma
i'm gonna sit and i'm gonna wait for the
solution to self-driving cars to come
along
this year i saw it it's been a zero yeah
so uh sit back and let the winning roll
in
so your sense just to elaborate a little
bit
to link on the topic your senses in your
networks will solve driving
yes like we don't need anything else i
think the same way chess was maybe the
chess and maybe google are the pinnacle
of like
search algorithms and things that look
kind of like a star um
the pinnacle of this era is going to be
self-driving cars
but on the path of that you have to
deliver products
and it's possible that the path to full
self-driving cars
will take decades i doubt it so how long
would you put
on it like what what are we
you're chasing it tesla's chasing it
what are we talking about five years 10
years 50 years in the 2020s
in the 2020s the later part of the 2020s
well the neural network well that would
be nice to see and on the path to that
you're delivering products
which is a nice l2 system that's what
tesla's doing a nice l2 system
better every time l2 the only difference
between l2 and the other levels is who
takes liability and i'm not a liability
guy i want to take liability
level 2 forever
you